This lecture is about the methods for
text categorization.
So in this lecture were going to
discuss how to do text
categorization.
1st.
There are many methods for text
categorization
In such a method, the idea is to
determine the category based on some
rules that we design carefully to
reflect the domain knowledge about the
categorization problem.
So, for example, if you want to do
topical categorisation for news
articles, you can say if the news
article mentions word like game and
Sports three times that we're going to
say it's about sports.
Things like that and this would allow
us to deterministically decide which
category A document should be put into.
Now such a strategy would work well if
the following conditions hold.
First, the categories must be very well
defined, and this allows the person to
clearly decide the category based on
some clear rules.
Secondly, the categories
have to be easy to distinguish based on
surface features in text, so that means
superficial features like keywords or
punctuations or whatever.
You can easily identify text data.
For example, if there is some special
vocabulary that is known to only occur
in a particular category, and that
would be most effective because we can
easily use such a vocabulary or pattern
of such a vocabulary to recognize this
category.
Now we also should have sufficient
knowledge.
For designing these rules and so if
that's the case, then such a method can
be effective, and so it does have a
provisions in some domains and
sometimes.
However in general there are several
problems with this approach.
First, of course it's labor intensive.
It requires a lot of manual work.
Obviously we can't do this for all
kinds of categorization problems.
We have to do it
From scratch for a different
problem, becauses different rules would
be needed so it doesn't scale up as
well.
Secondly, it cannot handle
uncertainties in rules.
Often the rules aren't 100% reliable take
for example, and looking at the
occurrences of words in text and try to
decide the topic.
It's actually very hard to have 1%
correct the rule.
So for example, you can say if it has
games, sports, basketball, then for
sure it's about sports.
But one can also imagine some text
articles that mention these keywords.
But that may not be exactly about the
sports, or only marginally touching
sports.
The main topic could be another topic,
different topic then sports.
So that's one disadvantage of this
approach, and then finally the rules
may be inconsistent and this would need
to concern about robustness more
specifically, and sometimes the results
of categorization may be different
depending on which rule to be applied.
So in that case then you will face
uncertainty and you will also have to
decide the order of applying the rules
or combination of results that are
contradictory.
So all these.
Problems with this approach, and it
turns out that the both problems can be
solved or alleviated by using machine
learning.
So these machine learning methods are
more automatic, but I still put
automatic in quotation marks cause
they're not really completely automatic
because it still require manual work.
More specifically, we have to use human
experts to help in two ways.
First, the human experts must annotate
datasets with category labels, will
tell the computer which documents
should not receive which categories.
And this is called a training data.
And then Secondly the human experts
also need to provide a set of features
to represent each text object that can
potentially provide a clue about the
category.
So we need to provide some basic
features for the computers to look
into.
And in the case of text, natural choice
would be the words.
So using each word as a feature is a
very common choice to start with.
But of course there are other sophisticated
features like phrases or
even policy feature tags or even
syntactic structures.
So once human experts can provide this,
then we can use machine learning to
learn soft rules for categorization
from the training data.
So soft rules just means we're going to
still decide which category should be
assigned to the document.
But it's not going to be used using a
rule that is deterministic, so we might
use something similar to saying that if
it matches game sports many times, it's
likely to be a sports.
But we're not going to say exactly for
sure, but instead we're going to use
probabilities or weights so that we can
combine multiple evidences, so the
learning process basically is going to
figure out which features are most
useful for separating different
categories.
And it's going to also figure out how
to optimally combine features to
minimize errors of categorisation on
the training data, so the training data
as you can see very important.
It's the basis for learning.
And then the train classifier can be
applied to a new text object to
predict the most likely category, and
that's to simulate the prediction of
what a human would assign to this text
object.
If the human would to make a judgement.
So when we use machine learning for
text categorization, we can also talk
about the problem in the general
setting of supervised learning.
So the setup is.
To learn a classifier to map a value of
X into a map of Y.
So here X is all the text objects.
And Y is all the categories a set of
categories, so the classifier would
take any value in X as input and we
generate the value in Y as output, and
we hope the output Y would be the right
category for X, and here correct of course
is judged based on the training data,
so that's the general goal, like in all
the machine learning problems or
supervised learning problems where you
are given some examples of
Input and output for function and then
the computer is going to figure out how
the function behaves like based on
these examples and then try to be able
to compute the values for future access
that we have not seen.
So in general, all methods would
rely on discriminating features of text
objects to distinguish different
categories, so that's why these
features are very important and they
have to be provided by humans.
And they will also combine multiple
features in a weighted matter with
weights to be optimized to minimize the
errors on the training data.
So ultimately, the learning processes
optimization problem and the objective
function is often tide to the errors on
the training data.
Different methods tend to vary in their
ways of measuring the errors on the
training data.
They might optimize a different object
function, which is often also called a
loss function or cost function.
They also tend to vary in their ways of
combining the features, so linear
combination for example is simple is
often used.
But they're not as powerful as non
linear combination, but nonlinear
models might be more complex for
training.
So there are tradeoffs as well, but
that would lead to different variations
of.
Many variations of these learning
methods.
So in general, we can distinguish the
two kinds of classifiers at a high level
one is going to generative classifiers.
The other is called discriminative
classifiers.
The generative classifiers try to learn
what the data looks like in each
category.
So it attempts to model the join the
distribution of the data and the label
X&Y.
And, this can then be factored out to
a product of Y.
The distribution of labels and join the
probability of sorry the conditional
probability of X given Y so it's Y.
So we first model distribution of
labels and then we model how the data
is generated given a particular label
here.
And once we can estimate these models,
then we can compute this
conditional probability of label given
data based on.
The probability of data given label.
And the label distribution here by
using the base rule.
Now this is the most important thing
'cause this conditional probability of
the label can then be used directly to
decide which label is most likely.
So in such approaches, the objective
function is actually likelihood, so we model
how the data are generated, so only thus it
only indirectly captures the training
errors.
But if we can model the data in each
category accurately, then we can also
classify accurately.
One example is naive Bayes classifier.
In this case.
The other kind of approaches are called
discriminative classifiers.
These classifiers try to learn what
features separate categories, so they
directly tackle the problem of
categorisation or separation of
classes.
So sorry for the problem.
So these discriminative classifiers
attempted to model the.
Conditional.
Probability of the label given the data
point directly.
So the objective function tends to
directly measure the errors of
categorisation on the training data.
Some examples include the logistical
regression support vector machines and
the K nearest neighbors.
We will cover some of these classifiers
in detail in the next few lectures.